[Musique]
avec Anthony Saint-Léger bonsoir Anthony
bonsoir à tous on va s'intéresser ce
soir au conflit dans le Nord qui vous
c'est dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo après les frappes
à me laisser de semaine par l'armée
congolaise contre des positions du M23
des vidéos affirmateurs que le mouvement
rebelle est en route effectivement et
des affirmations qui est ma
essentiellement de compte Twitter et
Facebook favorable au président
congolais Félix Tshisekedi premier
exemple le voici ou la voici plus
précisément c'est cette vidéo où l'on
entend des échanges de tirs on y voit
des affrontements des dizaines d'hommes
en uniforme militaire qui combattent on
voit des armes automatiques également
une vidéo partagée massivement notamment
sur Facebook à l'image de cette
publications par exemple qui cumule vous
voyez plus de 500 000 vues alors que
nous disent les comptes qui partagent la
vidéo en question et bien que les faits
sont récents qu'ils ont lieu regardé à
boun c'est où c'est ici on est dans le
Nord qui vous en République démocratique
du Congo à proximité de l'Ouganda et du
Rwanda et elle est publications
d'ajouter donc cette ville qui est
occupée depuis quelques mois maintenant
par le M23 et bien ferait
assisterait en fait à la fuite du M23
après ses frappes aériennes menées par
l'armée congolaise et que donc la ville
de bounagana aurait été libérée du M23
pourquoi est-ce que c'est faux et bien
tout simplement regardez pourquoi il y a
plusieurs indices qui vont permettre de
mettre en doute ses affirmations le
premier indice il se trouve ici c'est
cet homme ou surtout son uniforme les
couleurs de son uniforme et plus
particulièrement aussi cette corde rouge
que l'on voit pourquoi parce que cet
uniforme on le retrouve ici on le
retrouve également là et ces deux photos
elles viennent d'une page facebook pas
n'importe laquelle page Facebook
officielle de la mini administration
police service du Kenya rien à voir donc
avec la République démocratique du Congo
le deuxième indice il est ici cette fois
c'est ce compte TikTok que l'on voit
l'auteur a été contacté par Arthur
Bahamas de la rédaction des Observateurs
de France 24 et derrière ce compte il y
a un membre de l'administration
poly-service du Kenya plus précisément
de cette branche par habilité dont
l'uniforme est spécifique il nous
explique être surpris du détournement de
sa vidéo puisqu'il en est l'auteur il
nous explique aussi que les images ont
été tournées en avril 2022 il y a
quelques mois donc où ça au Kenya
unakuru précisément au nord-ouest de
Nairobi la capitale et qu'il s'agit tout
bonnement d'un entraînement de police et
la recherche d'images inversée va
d'ailleurs confirmer qu'il n'y a aucune
trace de cette vidéo avant avril 2022 et
puis deuxième exemple Anthony la vidéo
concerne cette fois un militaire des
forces congolaises effectivement vidéo
que l'on va découvrir ensemble là aussi
partager depuis le
novembre cette vidéo là voici regardez
une minute trente environ d'une
interview d'un militaire congolais on
reconnaît ici l'écusson que dit ce
militaire que le M23 serait en fuite
vers le Rwanda et que la population de
ruchourou à la roue c'est ici c'est le
point rouge on est toujours dans le Nord
qui vous en République démocratique du
Congo à proximité de l'Ouganda et du
Rwanda que cette ville aurait été
libérée de l'occupation du M23 vidéo qui
selon les comptes qu'il a partagé donc
une preuve supplémentaire que l'armée
congolaise a défait le M23 récemment
après ses frappes aériennes il a encore
ses faux les images ne sont pas récentes
et là encore deux indices pour nous le
montrer regardez on va extraire une
image de la vidéo en question le premier
indice il est ici c'est un logo que le
que je vais grossir trois lettres VOA
pour Voice of America du nom du média
américain Voice of America donc la
première indice et le second il est ici
c'est la bande patronymique ici le nom
du militaire en question en l'occurrence
amoulie Olivier et lorsque vous combinez
ces deux indices et bien en faisant une
recherche par exemple sur Youtube vous
retrouvez la vidéo en question sur la
page de la chaîne officielle Youtube de
Voice of America rien d'étonnant il
s'agit d'une interview à l'époque
exclusive d'un militaire congolais qui
commente bien sa victoire de l'armée
congolaise sur le M23 mais regardez bien
il y a 9 ans et donc en 2013 et
effectivement à l'époque en 2013 donc le
M23 a été défait par l'armée congolaise
il a dû quitter le Nord prévu et à
l'époque effectivement Olivier Amélie
était bien porte-parole de l'armée
congolaise deux in Fox donc ce soir et
j'en terminerai là-dessus qui viennent
s'ajouter à la longue liste des fausses
informations qui ont été diffusées ces
derniers depuis le regain de tension
entre le M23 et l'armée congolaise et
d'ailleurs des infox qui viennent des
deux côtés à la fois des partisans de
l'armée congolaise et des partisans du
M23 et pour l'heure rude Chourou et
bounagana sont aux mains du M23 merci
beaucoup Antony on peut retrouver cette
chronique sur vos réseaux sociaux on
marque une très courte pause on se
retrouve dans une poignée de minutes
pour une nouvelle édition tout de suite